what advice would you give to uh young
people the both of you
that you have both audiences where young
people look up to you in general if you
were to give advice to somebody in high
school like how to
create a life they can be proud of what
would you say
the most important thing that I've
learned is to view people as different
and not better or worse and when you
view people is different it's not a
better or worse you learn that there's
almost something that you can learn from
anybody like being open and empathetic
towards other people's experiences
nobody does anything by random Choice
like there's always reasons why people
act the way they do and as long as
you're willing to kind of like be open
and receptive to the lived experiences
of other people you're going to be able
to gather information and create like a
more cohesive and better view of the
world than any of your peers will
do you have any kind of advice you can
give to Young Folks I've something that
I see especially in America a lot is
that a lot of people kind of get told
what to do early on like in high school
they're supposed to become this thing uh
like education wise like they're
supposed to like become a doctor or this
thing or whatever and then they kind of
just like give up on things that they're
actually passionate about so I think a
lot of teenagers get really confused
they get an education and then they get
that job and they hate everything and
they think that when they're when
they're reaching the job when they're
reaching like the journey they're going
to get happy that's like where the
happen is going to be but then when they
get to there they just hate everything
and then they go become really depressed
and I've seen this so much like I've
seen this all the time and it's it's
pretty sad to me to see so many people
that are just wasting time and then they
just get really confused and I don't
know it's the same thing with
relationships too no one really knows
what they want anymore I feel like
everyone is just kind of doing whatever
like Society is saying or the parents
are saying or their friends are saying
um they're never really doing anything
that's super meaningful anymore and like
they don't so what I would say is like
try to find something that that's that
is important to you it could be anything
really like some sort of passion maybe
like your friends maybe like like what
matters to you like figuring those
things out I think is really important
and that comes from being able to listen
to like some inner voice it's just not
gonna come from elsewhere it's really
hard because you're living the life and
like there's things happening around you
people tell you what to do and what not
to do I know you know no one really has
like their own opinions everyone is just
kind of like listening to the the cooler
thing or you know except even if he
seems to stand on his own yeah I'd say
so and like hashtag like something I
realized too like because we just went
to twitchcon and we were talking to a
lot of streamers
uh it was interesting I I thought it was
interesting because the the few people
that I feel like I that seem really cool
and that I look up to like in the
streaming world all of them wants to
quit streaming all them wants to do it
no one wants like no one likes it and
they're so successful like they are
around successful people they they're
working every single day they're working
hard they're making so much money and
everyone is just complaining and like
they're complaining about
um like not being able to see their
partner or you know because they need to
live somewhere else because and I see
these things and they seem extremely
unhappy and but it's so hard for them to
just cut all these successful stuff off
because that's like what you you know
learn to do and that's like supposed to
be like your happiness but it isn't
everyone is really unhappy yeah there's
something about maybe assuming is
different but you do folks to have
interacted with a few and
um even in podcasting space people
become obsessed about the views and
numbers and subscribers and stuff like
that
um so I turned I never talk about that I
I don't pay attention to that uh I feel
like that's a drug that destroys your
mind your your mind is an artist the
ability to create really unique things
um also your mind in terms of the
anxiety the ups and downs of the
attention mechanism uh and then also
being just if it's something that you
make is not popular but it meant a lot
to you you will think of it less yes
because it's not popular yeah that's a
really dangerous thing and because
everyone around you is reinforcing like
I'll get messages like wow this thing
got this many views or something great
job it's like no you don't get it like
that's not that's not everyone is
enforcing this like this language of
views and likes and so on and it's it's
correlated of course because truly
impactful things will get a lot of
attention often but it's not on the
individual local scale like temporarily
is
it's uh it can really [ __ ] with your
mind and I see that in the creators they
become
um addicts to the algorithm lost in
chasing views like we know friends that
yes we know cool people and they start
streaming and eventually they go they're
like chasing the dragon of like
and they change like they're yeah it's
like really and there's like this is
something I've always said that like one
of the biggest blessings and biggest
curses of humanity is we are very good
at acclimating like you can become
paralyzed you can have all sorts of
horrible things happen to you and you'll
get used to it and you'll be okay you're
gonna have like a good Baseline but it
works the other way too and that you can
get more and more and more and more and
you acclimate to it almost immediately
there's like this is a phenomenon that I
bet it happens in the YouTube world but
I know what happens in the steering
world where you're streaming 1000
viewers every day huge event happens and
you blow up and you got like 15 000
viewers for a day or two and then it
starts to go down and down and down and
down and down and then after all the
drama started off you're at like 3 000
concurrent viewers now in the macro you
went from one thousand to three thousand
that feels awesome but you actually feel
like [ __ ] the whole time because you're
remembering when you had 10 or 15 000
and now Everything feels horrible and
you'll see people climb over time like
[ __ ] like but whatever that one huge
stream I had like I've never like been
able to and it's like dude you're doing
great what's yeah that happens a lot
there's so many people that we know that
we find super super cool they're
passionate about things they have so
much interest
and then they just get like so addicted
to these numbers and like all the
everything is just ruined like all the
cool things about them is ruined because
they stop doing the things that they
actually like
to do something else that gives the more
viewers more money and it's really sad
to see yeah that temporary sacrifice
that seems
temporary is that it uh it actually
destroys you like for one time making a
choice because I come across those
choices often like I can do this you can
kind of know what's going to be popular
and not and you have to ask yourself the
question like is this gonna sacrifice
because if people are sacrificing like
intimate relationships they're
sacrificing time with their family their
sex sacrificing time with things that
they feel good about and that they like
and that's something I kind of realized
last year because I was working so much
and I was just grinding and grinding
grinding but because it was kind of new
for me and then New Year's came by and I
was like wait what did I even do like
the entire year like I traveled to a
bunch of places but nothing actually
really meant anything to me because I
felt like I was just working the entire
time I felt like I was just numb through
the through the entire year and I was
really scary
um like I rented a like a super pretty
house like for a week with my dad and my
sister because I wanted to spend time
with them but the entire time I was just
streaming and I actually didn't ever
like calm down and just like chill with
them and I like that's like time I'll
never get back I don't I don't give a
[ __ ] about the money that I made that
week but I lost the time
and like that is really important to me
and I yeah and a lot of people are doing
that um and I feel like you as you said
like you can definitely see that in like
artists for sure I feel like if you look
at like artists like back in the 60s or
70s I feel like things were just so much
better back then and it feels like they
were actually making music that meant
something to them they were actually
making art and I feel like today
everything is just kind of like whatever
is cool whatever sells whatever you know
sounds in a certain way everything is
kind of the same thing and everything
that is very artistic and very cool is
actually not that popular at all and uh
that's kind of sad I think yeah of
course there's now bigger mechanisms and
platforms to spread stuff music so as
long as you could be content with not
being popular I think you can still
create yeah but not like when people get
a little popular they get addicted to
that so fast yeah it's weird yeah you
have been somewhat good at least from my
outside of perspective because I think
you I can at least imagine you making
choices that could make you more popular
and you don't seem to make those choices
sabotage
but it is very intentional like you said
like and I made that choice at every
single stage of My Life One is because
from the perspective of being a carpet
cleaner my life is way better than that
was or ever would have been so I'm
already doing way better than I ever
thought somebody like me ever could be
um but then two I super love my job
every time I wake up every time I fly to
a place to do a podcast every time I get
to talk to really cool people like every
single part of my job I super like if
there's something I don't like I just
cut it off because I don't care because
I'm already making plenty of money doing
what I do and why would I ever wake up
and not like what I'm doing when I kind
of like what I'm doing